[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday January 30th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the collapse of cryptocurrency exchange
FTX was Swift and has left a lot of
casualties among them is a large group
of African customers in the days before
ftx's implosion before it froze customer
accounts and eventually filed for
bankruptcy it was heavily recruiting
Africans to invest on the platform it
lured customers in Kenya Nigeria Ghana
South Africa and other countries across
the continent now as FTX goes through
bankruptcy in the U.S and the company's
new management tries to locate customer
funds many of those people don't know if
they'll ever see their money again
joining me to discuss this is our
johannesburg-based reporter Alexandra
Wexler hi Alexandra thanks for being
here thanks so much for having me
so to start with why was FTX recruiting
customers in Africa it's a really fast
growing market for cryptocurrencies a
lot of these exchanges position
themselves as a safe haven to store
money much like a Traditional Bank
against tumbling local currencies and
oftentimes runaway inflation in a lot of
these markets what were some of the
tactics that FTX used to attract
customers on the African continent so
they used a lot of marketing they had
events that people would speak at who
were experts or self-proclaimed experts
in cryptocurrency markets where they
would educate people about
cryptocurrency how to invest in
cryptocurrency and also how to use the
FTX app and then they had a lot of these
what they called ambassadors oftentimes
University students they were campus
ambassadors who would host events at
their universities and if they had a
certain number of people attend FTX
would pay them and FTX would sponsor
things like refreshments and marketing
materials to try to attract people to
these events and oftentimes they would
also have giveaways attached so
merchandise was a big thing so FTX hats
or FTX t-shirts and then if you signed
up for an FTX account then there were
often some kind of sign up bonus so five
dollars maybe more that could be used
towards trading fees
you know apart from crypto just being
popular in Africa was there something
particularly appealing about FTX or
about crypto In This Moment before the
FTX collapse yes absolutely so because
of runaway inflation worldwide a lot of
African currencies have been doing
really poorly especially against the
dollar so one of the main selling points
for FTX and for cryptocurrency at this
exact moment kind of over the last year
has been that you can store your money
in US dollars in stable coins so you can
store your naira or your Ghanaian Sadies
or your Kenyan shillings in stable coins
which could be US dollar denominated or
other currencies so you were able to
actually store your money not in these
local currencies
was there a difference in these
investors compared with say U.S or
european investors yes so the African
investors used FTX and crypto much more
as you would a traditional bank account
so to store your money in a safe place
in a safe currency and then also they
use crypto a lot more for day-to-day
transactions Alexandra you spoke with
some of these people who were FTX
investors who were brand ambassadors for
them can you tell us some of their
stories one person that I spoke to was
Muhammad Sabu who's 27 and he started
working for FTX in August so relatively
recently he was trading crypto for a
living because he thought that he could
make more money doing that than at the
job he had previously and so he got
involved with FTX he answered some
questions on an official FTX telegram
group in in hausa which is a language
widely spoken in Northern Nigeria and so
they hired him as an ambassador and he
was paid 800 a month plus 200 for
marketing materials to educate people
about FTX and cryptocurrency and get
people to sign up for accounts and trade
on the platform he lost about two
thousand dollars he had in FTX when it
filed for bankruptcy which was money
that he was due to transfer for the
balance of payment for a piece of land
in his hometown where he wanted to open
up a blockchain school to teach people
in his hometown in the area more about
cryptocurrency trading so he's ended up
with just one third of the property
because that was a down payment that
he'd made before FTX imploded so now
basically his plans for his blockchain
school are on hold he's back to earning
maybe a hundred dollars a month and
instead of a thousand which is a big
difference especially because he has a
one-year-old son so he's you know kind
of back to square one and also you know
feeling very badly about having so many
of his neighbors and community members
sign up for this platform and also lose
money on it
what's the general feeling then from FTX
investors in Africa who seem to at the
moment have lost their funds yeah you
know it seems to be a relatively Common
Thread that they obviously are kind of
flabbergasted that this happened and
disappointed because a lot of them
really believed in the Sam bankman freed
message of altruism and kind of I don't
know if you can say saving the world
through cryptocurrency a lot of them
really bought into that idea but as a
general rule they also seem to still be
into cryptocurrency and they still want
to invest in it and they want to own it
and they want to use it to further kind
of Their Own
Financial plans so yeah I think that
despite the fact that a lot of people
lost money or have money stuck with FTX
I haven't talked to one person who said
that it had turned them off of crypto
have FTX or Sam bankman freed commented
on its Africa business or the customers
there so Sam bankman freed said via a
spokesman that one of his biggest
regrets is letting down the customers
and employees of FTX and FTX the company
hasn't said anything specifically about
the African customers all right that's
our reporter Alexandra Wexler Alexandra
thanks for joining us thanks so much and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
if you want more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]